hua halter das passt gar nicht zusammen
da verschenkt hätte das gedacht und
herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video ja leute ich hoffe natürlich geht
es gut
ihr habt heute laune mitgebracht dieses
video zu schauen und ich habe auch
richtig spaß ich hab mich gerade auch
dass der plattform hält wir schon
gesehen habt heute geht es um fünf
minuten terrine ich schaue mir auch
selber wissen noch nicht vor aber das
ist mal wieder so ein video wurde von
euch und zwar habe ich auf dem momentan
lesen wenn ich gefragt habe wie sie
jetzt aus welche essens videos sondern
kommen alex testet doch mal fünf minuten
terrine deswegen habe ich ein paar
supermärkte abgeklappert und habe
insgesamt neun stücke kauft alles
verschiedene die haben zum beispiel reis
wir haben kartoffel frei wir haben
maggetti von esel gaben pasta in
ziegenkäse soße chinesischen nudeln und
noch ganz viel weiteres zeug und das
werden wir jetzt alles gleich machen an
die leute die nicht wissen wie das
funktioniert eigentlich ganz einfach wir
sind zutaten drin da kommen kochendes
wasser rein bis zusammenstrich und dann
hat man halt wirklich anziehen bis jetzt
alles was ich dachte gestern zwar nicht
einen klettere ich gebe natürlich wie
immer bei essen jeder sache punkte von
eins bis zehn ist das beste und wir
schauen mal was heute am besten
abschalten und somit gewinnen und ich
empfehle allen west glaube wir müssen
einander zum wasserkocher so ich habe
den wasserkocher mal ganz voll gemacht
weil wir werden auf jeden fall eine
menge brauchen für diese ganzen fünf
minuten terrine leute an dieser stelle
bitte in die kommentare weitere ideen
für essens videos macht ultrabook
deswegen ich bin wirklich mal angewiesen
auf eure ideen so kochend heißes wasser
mein fuß macht über dich so leute ich
hab ich jetzt dazu entschieden den
benutzt nur eine hand weil ich habe
keinen bock eingabe zu wie der name
schon sagt das ganze dauert fünf minuten
wenn man es
füllt gehen raus an jupiter der kamera
den letzten gefragt hat entweder dauert
eigentlich dass wir von so etwas wie
meine eltern mal gesagt haben wer lesen
kann ist klar im vorteil
oder das schwarz ist die schrift okay
geben hier passt seinen käse alles klar
gemacht
sie ist das hier aber das kriegt gar
nicht gut muss ich sagen ich habe mich
am anfang immer gewinnen da das war
wirklich so viel wasser rein muss weil
man denkt er jetzt da ist eigentlich
viel zu viel wasser drin aber das muss
so sein denn der titel recht
unappetitlich aus der schmeckt echt gut
oder sogar bereit als nächstes kommen
wir zu xxl gulasch nudeltopf mal dass
richter auf jeden fall schon mal besser
aber es fällt irgendwie überall auf das
ist sehr chemische ich finde ich oder
also das richtig naturell sagen machen
so ich will das jetzt alles sehr schnell
mal auf das ist ja auch langweilig ne
cologne asse kommen wir hier haben wir
sogar stent wird ist das aroma und
macken
das kommt doch erst wahrscheinlich muss
rein das wird halt wirklich mal
kartoffelbrei habe ich noch nie probiert
linsen tauschen mit kartoffeln
das sieht aus wie schokoladen stücke
oder wie katzen scheiße gemacht
wieso müsli unsere guter letzt haben wir
auch ich dachte eigentlich dadurch dass
es reicht wenn ich auch mal gespannt wie
die im flieger
neun stück hat so gerade gereicht also
jetzt wirklich nicht mehr viel drin
ok so jetzt wenn das ganze ungerührt ich
weiß ist bisschen blöd dass wir nur eine
gabe dafür benutzen aber weiter das ist
schon jetzt guck mal was mit den
kartoffelbrei passiert
[Musik]
ich muss auch wirklich sagen die ich
kenne diese fünf minuten tarim erst
seitdem ich eine eigene wohnung und habe
vorher so immer mama hat gekocht sagt
karl so was gar nicht in meinen kopf
rein das ist sowas gibt oder dass man
hier gefühlt
irgendwann mal auf sowas angewiesen ist
wenn es halt mal schnell gehen muss
deswegen also wenn ihr zuhause auszieht
denkt an meinen reden also ich muss
sagen dass chinesische hier sieht bis
jetzt immer unappetitlicher aus und der
linseneintopf oder die zwar aus wie so
kleine made
jetzt habe ich alles um gehört das heißt
world of tui heute schon erledigt es
waren wir machen mal fünf minuten und
dann sollte das ja alles test war sein
oder bin ich mal gespannt was hier
gewinnen aber wir können ja mal eine
reihe machen dann probiere ich das alles
nach der reihe
[Musik]
so wird erst mal genüsslich eine kleine
chor oder auch zwischendurch weil ich
muss noch lange durchhalten werden noch
einige videos produzieren und an dieser
stelle kommt nicht aus neuen dank für
das nette paket hier mit dem leckeren
getränken und der tollen kleidung hat
mich sehr gefreut auf euch was würdest
du sagen mit am besten sein
ich glaub gulasch und kartoffelbrei auf
jeden fall also ich tippe darauf dass
reiss karriere auf kartoffelbrei alles
klar wir fangen wir an mit pastorin
ziegenkäse soße habe ich wirklich noch
nie probiert ich bin gespannt wie ich
eigentlich ganz gut
ich muss jetzt einmal probieren bei den
wieder schmeckt so also es schmeckt sehr
sehr leicht nur nach zu ziegenkäse oder
nudeln das mit sehr neutral dieses
gericht oder diese art von terrine sage
ich jetzt nur schmeckt nicht schlecht
aber mir fehlt ein bisschen der
geschmack häufig um fangen wir erstmal
mit vier von zehn punkten ist in ordnung
weil eigentlich nicht eigentlich
schmecken ließen gut obwohl so was muss
ja geschmack habe deswegen sind die
firma zehn punkte absolut berechtigt ich
habe jetzt voll den komischen
nachgeschmack also das war wirklich
nicht so
dann sind wir jetzt auch direkt schon
hier beim reis curry wie gesagt ich
glaube so was habe ich letztens mal
irgendwann im flugzeug bekommen liegt ja
auch nahe die vermutung dass sie hat
einfach so da der preis auf kochen oder
wie auch immer muss ich auch sagen
schmeckt mit zu künstlich also klar dann
ist auch alles sehr künstlich das hat er
hier nichts mit großen brocken zu tun
deswegen soll das jetzt auch gar kein
vorwurf sein oder so trotzdem zum
beispiel wir dieses gericht bahamas habe
ich auch schon mal gegessen und das
finde ich sehr lecker und das setzt sich
dann von diesem reichs der übrigens nur
55 cent gekostet hat schon ab obwohl man
auch sagen kann so ey dass du das kannst
du auf jeden fall essen wenn man hunger
hat aber es ist jetzt muss geil
deswegen gibt es von mir hier leider
auch nur vier von zehn punkte wir müssen
die abwehr bleiben
ok als nächstes kommen wir zum
linseneintopf mit karotten da werden den
löffel eigentlich besser als es ist
schön am dampfen
warum oder trägt also dass sie mit
abstand am schlimmsten aus aber es
schmeckt eigentlich gut also ist
deutlich besser als diese beiden
obwohl ich gar nicht mal so einen
linseneintopf werden bin deswegen
überraschend
das kann man wirklich gut essen meine
mama kriegt gut gemeint die sieben von
zehn punkte lässt sich jetzt nichts
pascal touzeau aber es ist in ordnung
julia immer solchen gute idee hier rein
jetzt nachdem punktzahlen auf das heißt
hier ist das schlechteste und hier
wird's besser alles klar kommen wir als
nächstes zu spaghetti bolognese
die kenne ich glaube ich schon habe ich
schon mal probiert schmeckt voll in
ordnung aber wir machen mal gerade mal
das fleisch kommt halt nicht rein da
passt irgendwie gar nichts zusammen bei
der hier das schmeckt wie wenn man bei
haben jahre und dann mit schlechten
koffer erwischt so schmeckt da 30 auch
bei den vier punkten ein es ist jetzt
nicht schlechter als diese beiden hier
aber auf keinen fall besser als der
linse tor alles klar als nächstes
kombinationen kartoffelbrei muss ich
auch sagen die jetzt optisch mich so
geil aus sich aber umso leckerer man
hier
da bin ich jetzt wirklich mal gespannt
weil ich bin absolut mit kartoffelbrei
aufgewachsen das gab es bei uns immer zu
hause weil jeder deutsche familie glaube
ich und da habe ich jetzt mal gespannt
auf der kartoffelbrei da mithalten kann
mama ich bring mir nicht einfach 18
solcher kleinen töpfen mit also das echt
mega gut also möglich so überzeugen wie
vollkommen vor allem da sind auch so
kleine frühstück finde ich halte es
überhaupt nicht einschätzen wie gesund
oder ungesund das ist aber so ungesund
ist es glaube ich nicht ich sehe oft
entfernen so beiträge über leute die
vielleicht nicht so viel geld haben und
die dann halt überlegen jemand über die
runden kommt aber das hier also wenn man
sich da von 22 so kleine töpfchen gönnt
ich glaube dass ich seit ich schon ganz
gut so und das ist kostet dann halt
wahrscheinlich 179 oder im iso deswegen
also wenn ihr das noch nicht probiert
habt und mal schnell was braucht nimmt
das auf jeden fall war mit mir schmeckt
so gut deswegen gibt es auch von mir
verdiente neun von zehn punkte ich wäre
jetzt noch keine 10 von 10
wir haben noch ein paar sachen
vielleicht ändert das später noch wir
werden sehen ob er als nächstes haben
wir hier die nudel kapstadt mit black
pepper in paprika und kartoffelbrei ob
das verschwinden weil an der gabel war
noch kartoffelbrei letzten mal gucken ob
die mit denen honda teams mithalten
können
die sind sogar ein bisschen spaß muss
ich auch sagen spenden richtig lecker
wenn ich jetzt diese nudeln mit dingen
die vergleiche die haben richtigen
geschmack diese hier schmecken irgendwie
kaum nachbarn asse deswegen also das ist
in welchen unterschied
ich würde diese hier sogar auch mit
neuen einreihen das heißt alles was bis
jetzt probiert haben bei dem eine
steigerung da wäre ich gar nicht wissen
wie dieser kartoffelbauer management
alles klar okay nun bei den muss ich
jetzt sagen warum auch immer dies mit
ein richtig richtig gut die haben ja
schon zweimal so gegriffen mega geil ich
bin echt lecker als ich glaube also ich
glaube ich habe auf jeden fall noch viel
zu tun heute abend wenn ich das essen
hier sehe ich muss das auf eine stufe
setzt mit denen hier wenn nicht sogar
bisschen hören kann man auch 9,5
parteien an ihre ski wird das 905 punkte
wenn ja dann war er weg gemacht und da
kann man so alles klar
dann gibt es von mir hier 95 punkte also
der gulasch muster der jetzt die zehn
sein und das hier ist ein elf- oder wie
kommen wir als nächstes zum gulasch
nicht auf jeden fall so wie wenn man
irgendwie auf dem land ist und dann
irgendwo einkehrt zurast und nicht so
eine alteingesessene deutsche töte
kommen gut essen gibt hier muss ich
leider schon wieder sagen da fehlen mir
ein bisschen der geschmack also ist in
ordnung also bis jetzt war noch nichts
mehr ich muss das mit fünf burgen jetzt
zwischen ein rein und dann haben wir zu
guter letzt den kartoffelbrei mit
rosmarin und kuba aber das passt gar
nicht zusammen da verschicken hat mich
alles kommt im welten nicht an diesen
kartoffelbauern nur manche sind sogar
von der gleichen markt oder das hier ist
halt mit rosmarin kann sein dass es
daran liegt es will muss hier und wir
sagen das reiht sich hier zwischen einen
bei ebenfalls fünf punkten und somit
haben wir einen ganz klaren sieger mit
95 punkten
spaghetti im käse sahne soße dicht
gefolgt von diesen beiden und den rest
kann man eigentlich praktisch schon
klicken also ich weiß jetzt wenn es bei
mir mal schnell gehen muss dann kaufe
ich einfach diese drei hier kann ich
euch auch mal empfehlen wollte ich hoffe
dieses kleine essens wieder
durchgefallen ich wollte einfach mal
ausprobiert auch wenn es jetzt nicht so
aufwendig war oder sonstwas dafür gibt
es jeden tag um 19 uhr neues video aus
dem kanal czech airlines ab da ist alex
w außer dem daumen nach oben geben
blogger aktivieren dankeschön